problem 52 colleen solves the equation 2
times 2x plus 5 is equal to 8 using the
following steps
okay so she has a bunch of steps to get
from step 2 to step 3 colleen so it's
good that i read the question before i
just started diving into it so to get
from step two to step three so this is
her step two and this is her step three
right here what did she do what did she
do on to get from here to here well she
divided both sides by four right you
could say you know 4 x is equal to minus
2. if you divide both sides of this
equation by 4
you divide both sides of this equation
by 4. the left-hand side these cancel
out you're just left with x and the hand
side minus two fourths is just minus
one-half so she just divided both sides
by four
and that is choice
a
she definitely didn't subtract four from
both sides she didn't add four to both
sides and she didn't multiply both sides
by 4 then we would have had 16x minus 8.
so that was actually a pretty
straightforward problem
and then 53 what is the reciprocal of ax
squared over y and this is another you
know you just kind of have to know what
a reciprocal is a reciprocal of
something is just 1 over that something
or if it's a fraction you just flip it
so if you have a over b
if the reciprocal is b over a
if you have i don't know
x
x y over a b
the reciprocal is going to be a b over x
y
so if you have a
x squared over y its reciprocal is just
going to be y
over a x squared that easy
and that is choice that is choice
d y over ax squared you just have to
know to flip this fraction right there